[Music]
in terms of content the action thriller
greenland is about a giant comet that is
heading for the earth contrary to the
claims of many scientists
the orb does not burn up instead a
single fragment of the comet is enough
to destroy the entire state of florida
the evacuation of a number of selected
people including the main character john
garrett and his family
quickly begins from a military base the
selected group of people is then to be
taken to greenland as their lives the
only chance of survival
in a huge ride the families eventually
torn apart and faces the almost
impossible task of finding themselves
among the mob of
looters and protesters it is a thrilling
story that was well received despite its
digital only u.s release due to the
pandemic
and is still paid off at the box office
in some countries where the movie did
hit theaters
next the plot of part 2 will be
discussed thus viewers who have not yet
seen their first part should skip the
news due to the risk of spoilers
the sequel under the official name
greenland migration picks up directly at
the end of the forerunner and deals with
the further proceedings of the garrity
family who narrowly escaped death
following their stay in greenland the
three set out to fund a new home in a
completely devastated europe
not only will actress gerard butler and
marina baccarin return for the sequel
but so with the duo of director rick
roman wow and chris sparling
when exactly greenland migration will be
released is still unknown but of course
we will keep you up to date on further
news
after the brilliant end of the first
season of the witcher there is now new
video footage of the netflix series
in the 12 second clip a closer look
revealed some clues about the course of
season 2.
we recognize a fiercely skilled and
sword fighting siri who has embroidered
the coat of arms of the kingdom of
syndra in the form of a golden lion on
her cloak she presumably states that the
witch's fortress of care more than ass
can also be seen from a mural of a
warrior fighting a monster
a classic witch's activity likewise of
interest is an ornate dare that could
have come from the school of the viper
this is especially noteworthy since the
witcher's guild is an invention of the
video games and does not
appear in the books in addition at the
request of many fans the nilfgaardian
troops armor has been redesigned after
it didn't look very satisfactory in the
first season
there are certainly even more clues
which is why we are interested in what
you noticed in the short teaser
feel free to write it down in the
comments you will probably be able to
watch the second season of the witcher
in december but unfortunately there is
no official release date
yet we are still about a year away from
the release of jurassic world dominion
but to the delight of many fans there's
some exciting news about the third part
of the series
the first news involves a new image
shared by director colin trevorrow
on it can be seen a small feathered
dinosaur which seems to be making a mess
of the remains of a larger one
after many fans wondered about this
species trevorrow announced the
scientific name of the creature
namely moro's intrepidus the small
detail with the feathers is also
deliberately staged in such a way
after all some scientific studies show
the dinosaurs were at least partially
covered with feathers
the leading paleontologists are still
not quite in agreement about the
feathers but nonetheless it is great to
see that scientific findings are dealt
with in the movie in addition
there was already your first official
movie poster to admire
besides the mosquito which is very
important for the franchise you can also
see a preview of an exclusive offer from
universal
if you go to watch the new fast and
furious 9 in an imax theater you will
get to see a 5 minute preview of
jurassic world in advance
this snippet also reveals that the
ending of jurassic world fallen kingdom
was set about 4 years before the new
part
a lot seems to have happened in this
rather short time jump as the dinosaurs
appear to be
slowly but surely reconquering the
planet we are looking forward to more
news about jurassic world dominion and
especially to the release on june 10th
2022
following aquaman's box office takings
of over 1.1 billion
us dollars it quickly became clear that
his sequel would be produced
immediately as director and horror icon
james 1 revealed on instagram with a new
photo this sequel will bear the name
aquaman and the lost kingdom fortunately
the title gives us a potential clue to
the plot of part 2 as
the lost kingdom is most likely one of
the seven kingdoms which includes the
underwater realm of atlantis
six of the seven kingdoms have already
been seen in sequences or by
representatives of their respective
kingdoms which is why part 2 will be
dedicated to the remaining
lost kingdom shooting for the dc
adventure will begin in the coming weeks
with a release expected on december 16th
2022 no one was expecting this
as variety and other outlets report a
completely new
lord of the rings movie is in the works
it will be produced alongside the amazon
series caroline production and
surprisingly it will be released as an
anime
the title is the lord of the rings the
war of the rohirim and we can look
forward to seeing how the team around
kanji kamiyama will direct the film
after all there are hardly any limits in
an anime adaption and the viewers are
offered a completely new view of middle
earth
although the story will largely stand on
its own two feet it will be based on
peter jackson's trilogy
what do you think of this certainly
unusual but not necessarily bad approach
to present the story of lord of the
rings as an anime please let us know in
the comments
after it had been unclear for a long
time whether the film would be produced
at all
we are now pleased to announce that
shooting of the upcoming indiana jones 5
has already begun it seems that james
mangold who replaced the originally
planned director steven spielberg at his
request
is the right man to direct the fifth
indiana jones movie
the film is barely in full swing and yet
the first unofficial photos from the set
have
already surfaced and they do reveal
quite a bit about the plot of the
upcoming film
they show hints of a third reich setting
as can be seen from the train or the
vermont uniforms
moreover there are indication that this
might be some sort of flashback
possibly with ford's facial features
rejuvenated on the computer
we are definitely eager to see if and
how the scene will appear in the final
film
and are looking forward to the release
date of indiana jones 5 on july 29th
2022 it has been known for over a year
that disney has plans for a prequel
series to beauty and the beast
after there had been no news for a long
time disney recently communicated that
the series is now
officially in production as has been
evident for some time
fans can look forward to gaston lefou
though an appearance by emma watson as
belle and dan stevens as the beast
should not be expected the internal
working title of the disney plus series
is
beauty and the beast and in addition to
luke evans gaston and josh gaddis lefou
brianna middleton is now joining the
cast in her role as lefou's stepsister
tilly as the synopsis states the trio
will embark on a journey filled with
romance
comedy and adventure as they uncover
secrets of their past
behind the scenes lead actor josh gad
and his colleagues edward kitchis and
adam horowitz are responsible for the
production
filming of the series is expected to
begin in spring 2022
yet an official release date has not
been announced so far
[Music]